So we've seen how two sounds in the verbs in the present tense might split when we put pressure on them
We've seen how E might become IE.
So for example we have querer which means to want but I want is
Quiero.
So we stress down on that e and it splits into IE.
And this will happen for the other versions that we learned as well.
So how do you say he wants or she wants or you foom will want?
Quiere.
They want?
Qieren.
Quieren.
Good.
A new informal.
Qieres.
Good.
What do you want?
Que quieres.
Yeah, que quieres.
Good.
So another example where this will happen is with the verb perder, which means to lose.
It's related to perish.
So how would you say I lose?
Pierdo.
Good.
And he loses.
She loses.
Pierde.
They.
Pierden.
Good.
And you informal?
Pierdes.
Good.
So we saw that the E can split into IE and
We also saw that an O in the base of the verb can split into U E.
So we saw for example, poder is to be able.
And then we have puedo, I can, I am able.
We had dormir.
What did dormir mean?
To sleep.
Good.
And duermo?
I sleep.
Good.
What changed when we added meh medware more?
Um I think it's uh I fall asleep.
Yes.
I sleep myself, I fall asleep.
Good
So we can expect to see these O's split, but not always.
For example, to eat was To Eat Comer and I eat
Como so it didn't split there.
So there's no way to know where it will, where it won't.
Most of the time it will, and you just have to kind of experiment and see what happens, and you will always get the feedback when you try to see if it splits or not.
You will also develop an intuition of where you should do it.
So Kolgar, for example, is to hang.
So if you want to say I hang,
Cuelco.
Cuelgo.
Good.
He hangs.
Quelke.
Quelk mm.
No, it's colgar.
Good.
So it's
Quelga.
Why do you think you said cuelge first?
Well the reason you explained before with the it sounds like it because it has a ne sound before
It seems to go more.
Exactly.
It fits more.
So you you will find yourself doing that.
How do you get out of doing that?
How do you stop that happening?
By going back to the to version of the verb.
Exactly.
And then you're in control.
Kolgar, our verb, cuelga.
Good.
They hang
Quelkan.
Good.
They hang it.
Loquelcan.
Loquelgan.
They hang them.
Los Quelcan.
Good.
She hangs them.
Los cuelga.
Good, los cuelga.
Words in English that begin al, so not end al like normal, normal, metal, metal, they begin al, they come from Arabic.
This A-L means the in Arabic and in Arabic it's written with the word.
It's written as one word.
It's all stuck together.
So when words came in from Arabic, they kind of came in most of the time.
the time with this al which meant the so for example alcohol and when we say the alcohol we are actually saying something like the the alcohol something like this
The verb to take is tomar.
Tomar.
T-O-M-A-R.
And this is also used like to drink.
So it's used like take.
generically generally but also to drink how would you say I don't drink alcohol I don't take alcohol
No tomo alcohol.
Good.
Sugar in Spanish is azúcar.
Azúcar.
Azucar.
Or in Spain, because we have a Zed here, it will be azucar in most of Spain.
Now, this is also an Arabic word, and it's the same word as sugar in English.
Might not look like it
What's happened here?
In Arabic, the El of Al, the word for the assimilates, changes to match the next letter if the next letter is kind of close to it.
It does this with about half the letters
So in Arabic actually instead of al-sukar you say as succar.
And this passed into Spanish.
But in English we got the word without the the at the beginning this time.
This time sugar came in without the the at the beginning.
So they look kinda different.
and sound rather different sugar azúcar but again they're the same word so how would you say I don't take sugar no tomo azúcar good no tomo azúcar
Arros, rice, is also an Arabic word.
It's actually al-ruz, the rice.
But again, in Spanish the El assimilated to the next A, as it does in Arabic.
And instead of al-Ruz, like in Arabic, arus, we ended up with aros.
So it's two ars.
Two ars.
So is a sugar a sugar with two S's?
No, it's with a Z here.
Because two S are not a combination you find in Spanish.
So for example, in the word possible
We have Q's there in English.
But in Spanish when we write possible, we write one es.
The same with passion.
We write one s
in Spanish pascion.
So you don't get two S's together in Spanish, but you do get two R's together to differentiate between the normal R and the rolling R.
So in Spanish we have A-R-R-O-Z.
It's just a simulation of alruz, arus, to Spanish, arroz.
And it's the same word as English, rice.
So how would you say I want rice?
Quiero arroz.
Good.
Algebra.
How would that be in Spanish?
Algebra?
Alge.
Algebra.
Good.
Spanish has a lot more Arabic than English.
The south of Spain was part of the Muslim world for 800 years, so the languages had a lot of contact.
And you get more words in Spanish that you don't have in English that are from Arabic.
So for example, aceite oyel.
In Arabic this is zept.
Aseite.
Aseituna, uh olive, zaytun, zaitun in Arabic, al-fombra, which means carpet, al-muada, which means pillow, all of these words they came in from Arabic.
When you find ael at the beginning,
with maybe a couple of exceptions, it's from Arabic.
So we said I take is Domma.
How is he take, she takes, it takes, you fumal take
Thomas.
Good.
You informal talking to a friend?
Thomas.
Good.
How would you say what are you taking?
This could be a way to ask what do you want to drink?
Ketomas.
The drink exists.
It's beber, beber, and the word drink, the noun, una bebida.
A drink.
Una we have A for feminine words.
Una bebida o la bebida, the drink comes from beber.
But tomar to take is extremely common.
They take Toman.
Toman.
Good.
Now there's one more version of the verbs that we didn't learn yet, which was the we version.
We didn't learn how to say we want or we have.
Now we take is tomamos.
Tomamos.
Explain to me what I did then to get we take.
If I go from tomar to tomamos, what am I doing?
You took out the R and put a MOS at the end.
But to make it fit in with your Well you took out the AR.
the R sound and you put in the amos good sound.
This is very nice to think about it this way because then you fit it in with what you've been doing up until now.
Taking off the R, A R, and putting on your ending.
So you take off R and you put on amos and you get the we form.
So how is to speak?
Ablar.
And we speak
Aplamos.
Ablamos.
Good.
So with amos we're adding on two syllables and the accent
is going on the second last syllable.
So it's in a different position, the accent, to the other versions.
If we look at tomo, toma, toman, tomas, tomamos.
The accent's moving.
Again, to speak.
Hablar.
I speak.
Hablo.
She speaks.
Abla.
They speak?
Ablan.
Are you in formal?
Ablas.
We
Ablamos.
Good.
So this affects the split of the E
or the O in the root of the verb because we said that it splits because you stress it.
But in the we form we don't actually stress it.
So let's look at this.
What was to find or to encounter?
I find encuentro I find or I'm finding.
He finds
Encuentra.
Good.
You went back to the two form, right?
Yeah.
They
Encuentran.
Good.
And you informal.
Encuentras.
Good.
Now we, you're not stressing that O anymore, so it's safe.
It's not gonna split.
Encontramos.
Very good.
We don't stress it so it doesn't split.
What was demonstration?
Demonstracion demostracion So how would you say to demonstrate
Demostrar.
If you take away this de, which actually means of in Spanish, if you get rid of it, you're left with mostrar.
And what does most mean?
To show.
I show or I'm showing.
Mostro.
It should be mostro, but good.
Muestro.
And he or she eat you fuman?
Muestra.
Good.
They or you guys?
Muestran.
You informal?
Muestras.
We
Mostramos.
Very good.
You're not accenting anymore that oh, so it doesn't split.
Mostramos.
How do you say to think?
And we said it's related to the word pensive.
Pensar.
Good.
I think.
Pienso.
They're the E splits when we stress it.
If you want to say I think so, you can just say I think that yes.
I think that yes.
That is the same as what?
Yeah.
Pienso che si.
Pienso que si.
I think so.
Pienso che si.
Good
He thinks or she thinks you formal think?
Piensa.
Good.
They?
Piensan.
You informal?
Piensas.
What do you think?
Good.
If you say what do you think to do, we said that this means what do you plan on doing?
You can just say what do you think to do?
What was to do?
To do or to make?
Which begins with a silent h
Assir.
Assir, good.
So what do you think to do?
What do you plan on doing?
Yeah.
You inform.
Good.
¿Qué piensas hacer?
Now, how would you say we think?
Pensamos.
Good.
So you're not splitting there.
Pensamos.
The verb to close, to close is serrar.
C-E-R-R-A-R cerrar.
Serrar.
Good.
Or in most of Spain, Cerrar.
How would you say I close?
Sierra.
Good.
She closes, he closes you for me, close.
Sierra.
Good.
So how would you say we close?
Sierramos.
Good.
So we're seeing that really this issue of the ease and the old splitting is an issue about stress and it's only when we stress them down that they split under that pressure.
When we don't, they are intact.
They stay intact.